and a graphics processor is a specialist
processor that is designed to make
processing of three-dimensional images
more efficient than other forms of
processor it is a digital world it's all
ones and zeros ads and minuses and if
you do lots of ads you turn it into a
multiply but actually a graphics
processor takes us very specialist
workload and does it much more
efficiently what are the fundamental
differences between essential processing
unit and a graphics processing unit well
fundamentally we're here to put pixels
on screens so at the end of the day the
we are here to execute some commands
whose purpose is to say that pixel on
that screen is that color and usually
that's presented to us as here's some
data so usually there's a
three-dimensional model so in front of
us is a table there's a circle which is
a few feet off the ground and it's X
thickness and it's got some legs and
it's at this position there's some
chairs in the room there's me there's
the walls all around there's a
three-dimensional model so first of all
you get given a bunch of coordinates and
say the following things are the
following places and then you say give
them to more data which is the chairs a
lie look and the tables are sort of
sludgy gray and suchlike and so you get
given some color information which is
what we call textures the geometry of
the scene is usually broken up into
triangles because triangles is nice and
simple we're very simple people we can't
cope with complicated stuff a triangle
three points always has to be flat
you've never seen a triangle isn't flat
and so you divide complex surfaces up
into triangles and then you have some
information about what color those
triangles are so you say right okay I've
got the geometry I've got the color what
do we do next where you put some lights
in the scene so there's some lights and
ceiling which are shedding some light in
certain directions and then you need a
camera so you say the camera is here so
now you have to do some
three-dimensional geometry to say well
what does it look like in the camera
and the first thing you observe is well
about half the room you can't see whew
that's a good that's good so I don't
have to calculate everything that's
behind you the only things I have to
calculate the bits you can see and you
project it so that it goes onto
two-dimensional screen and this is what
it looks like and then you move the
camera around usually to get a sort of a
real impression of moving through the
scene so there's a lot of different
types of calculation involved in that
first is or loads and loads and loads of
three-dimensional matrix arithmetic you
know XYZ coordinates sometimes four
dimensional arrays with XYZ and
transparency information and lots and
lots of RGB red green blue color so a
device that's really really good at
matrix arithmetic it's a good start
floating point because the positions of
all of these things they usually Express
this floating point and then finally
you've got this unit at the back which
says well I've got lots and lots of
pixels to deal with so we need to run
through that and get them all into a
buffer in memory so some of that's
really quite different from a CPU a lot
of three-dimensional plain equations
have to be solved so for example here's
the table here's the floor where which
bits of the floor and which bits of the
table can I see so you have to do a lot
of matrix solving to work that one out
and that's the difference in the problem
that gets given to us right the
difference in the design is we say well
actually I can do loads of this in
parallel because actually I can do a lot
of these calculations in parallel
because they don't depend on each other
so every time you hear the phrase for
every vertex in the geometry do la for
every pixel in the screen do foo you can
actually say well actually that's you
know that's a million pixels I can
actually calculate them in you know
batches of 256 or something like that so
we extract the parallel as a merit of
the algorithm and we design a processor
there's actually
very good at parallel processing so the
difference between a CPU and a GPU
predominantly is yes there's some really
really fixed function blocks which we do
very very efficiently compared to the
CPU which does everything in Sulphur but
also we are very very good at extracting
parallelism so if I want to multiply
three floating-point numbers together
I'll do it more slowly than a CPU but if
you ask me to multiply million three
floating-point numbers together then the
length of time it takes me to do a
million will be a lot shorter than the
time it takes a CPU to do a million so
we don't care so much about how long
anything individually takes what we work
on is the bulk throughput and it's a
different end of the problem and of
course there are blurred areas and some
people are now saying well actually
there's some sort of computing I could
do that would do better on a GPU than on
a CPU and so you get this whole thing
called GPU computing coming along where
people are not actually doing graphics
but they're doing throughput computing
and actually that's being quite an
interesting area because I think one of
the ones that somebody suggested was
people doing Bitcoin mining with GPUs
because it's just lots and lots of maths
yeah yeah but also image processing so
in modern modern devices you tend to
have quite a poor lens quite a poor
sensor and you're trying to take
pictures that are as good as that camera
you're holding in your hand that cost
thousands and actually that takes an
awful lot of image cleanup so there's an
awful lot of computing that's taking
place on those digital images and it
turns out that actually a lot of those
go quite well on when executing on GPUs
not executed on CPUs can it fix my bad
focusing as well that is coming that is
coming
so what have we done we've taken our
local representation moved it into a
world space constructive decision so if
you want to say one tenth in decimal you
say and a new hash is found about every
ten minutes so what happens is that
hundreds of people